So, let's take a closer look at our input data.
Remember that each mapper processes a portion of the input data.
And, each one will be given a line at a
time. The lines look like this. The mapper needs to take
that line, and extract the information it needs. Often, when
we're dealing with text, it's pretty free-form. So we'd use something
like a regular expression. But in this case, it's regular, it's
tab limited. So we can split the line on tab and
extract the values. In this example, they're date,
time, store name, product type, cost, and method
of payment. Let's say you've been asked to
find the total sales per store. How would you
choose an intermediate key and value? Could it
be the time and the store name? Or the
cost of the item and the store name? Or rather the store name as a key and
the cost? Or the store name and the
product type. Remember that our line looks like this.